um
we have a did you pay attention to the
grammy nominations
no so the the best rap album category
this year
was extremely it was some real hip-hop
[ __ ] they got nominated
really yeah i saw something online i
know freddie gibbs got nominated
freddie gibbs got nominated uh royce the
five nine got nominated
yeah royce yep royce j electronica
uh nas for kings disease and uh
and this kid from l.a named d smoke i'm
wondering
d smoke is um a really dope talented kid
from inklewood out here in la he's uh
he was on that show rhythm and flow on
netflix but really [ __ ]
amazing artist i'm wondering though what
was your favorite album of the year
of this year of this year busta rhymes
oh it's so good it's so good
yo tell me how crazy the farrakhan
speech is on there
and how it leads in the bust of spasm i
said
man people are so afraid of the truth
bro you know what i'm saying
and that's one thing i commend about
busta rhymes like
you know doing this album you know what
i'm saying because it's real times right
now and
you you know to say to do something else
other than something real
you know it ain't the move you know i'm
saying so
e ele is the best album in 2020
yo it's crazy too because it tells you
how important it is to make timeless
music because a lot of this album
some of these songs are 10 years old and
the fact that they still
resonate right now
like and then so you're part of the
intro
talk about how old that record is man
1992 and um
you know it was you know the joint i did
for nasa and right
he brought it back on some necks you got
that i thought it was dope he gave you
the feature
like it's a featuring pete rock i love i
love
busta rhymes we have a really good
relationship
going back since 1991 so
that's my guy you know i mean and um
you know [ __ ] man look
there was a lot of great music that came
out you know what i'm saying
but but the way some of the music that
you hear there's no real structure on
the album this
buster album has structure um
it's front to back front to back and you
can tell that buster cares about his
audience
you could tell that he made this album
for them
and you could tell that he is a hip-hop
in his heart all the way he he took the
time
on this album and in an era
where no one takes time on their
projects everybody's just
rushing and throwing stuff out and
there's no rush to throw music out